because I was raised right but I love
the Cowboys why do people love Cowboys
think about a cowboy
in command
stoic
sexy a little dirty too which is Plus
for me
you know they they take care of
themselves they typically own land they
know how to fix things I mean this is
just sexy as all hell you're not gonna
find a lot of that New York City New
York City you're gonna find like some
guy that drinks too much sake on your
date and then like puts you in a cab and
it's like yeah I hope you get home okay
I'll see you next time and you pay
you're like oh let me see I hope I have
cash for the cab anyway get home you
call your friend because they're not
calling you to check on you no thank you
no thank you okay I know I went off on a
tangent here don't get me started on
what I saw in City dating my
mom's gonna be like you're cursing a lot
today you know Mom you know you're
Italian too that's where I got it from
when the Sicilian and the Napoli Don
gets fired Up Girls Gotta Go